our 80s movie is about to have a massive
gaming moment plus a classic from the
n64 is finally coming to the switch all
this and more on today's gamespot news
the terminator will be back in an open
world survival game developed by nikon
milan a young studio with only the title
rims racing under its belt this untitled
terminator game will be set before the
events of judgement day when the war
between humans and machines began the
teaser image shows the t800 the robot
skeleton under arnold schwarzenegger's
synthetic skin in the films but no
detail so far on whether the iconic
actor or any characters from the films
will make an appearance the terminator
isn't the only 80s action movie being
revived by naycom robocop rogue city is
a first-person shooter featuring the
titular cybernetic police officer
faithfully recreating the precision and
brutality scene in the original film it
will be releasing in june 2023 and is
coming to pc ps5 xbox series consoles
and nintendo switch do you love your
quests too but hate the fact that you
have to have a facebook account
connected to it that your weird aunt
keeps sending friend requests to well
starting in august quest users will no
longer need to use their facebook
accounts to log in instead users will
need to create a new meta account in
order to use the headset this move is
all a part of meta's plan to continue
shifting away from the facebook brand as
well as a response to user
dissatisfaction with the facebook
account requirement in addition to login
credentials changing the oculus profile
will evolve into a new customizable
feature called meta horizon profiles
friends will also become followers in a
move made to become similar to
instagram's existing model if you
previously merged your oculus and
facebook account there will be an option
to decouple the two during the new meta
account setup process previously
purchased apps will also immediately be
available so now you can stop the
awkward excuses for not accepting family
members on facebook at thanksgiving and
simply say i don't have an account
anymore while you wait to decouple your
quest headset from your facebook account
why not relax with a little dose of
pokemon nostalgia nintendo has announced
that the n64 game pokemon puzzle league
is coming to nintendo switch online plus
expansion pack on july 15th that's one
week from the time of this recording so
make sure to mark your calendars and
while you've got your calendar open mark
the start of gamescom on august 24
because microsoft has announced it will
be there the company has yet to share
specifics around its plans but it did
confirm xbox will have a place on the
show floor and it will have some news to
share as well about games that have
already been announced according to
gamescom's organizers more than 250
companies are signed on to appear at the
event this year including ubisoft coke
media and bandai namco in terms of
companies that will not attend gamescom
these include nintendo activision
blizzard and sony among others gamescom
2022 will be a hybrid style event that
has both an in-person element and an
online show the opening night live
stream by games media veteran jeff keely
will mark the beginning of the event as
well speaking of jeff keely last year's
game awards ended with the reveal of the
matrix awakening a free unreal 5 demo
for ps5 and xbox series consoles that
demo which allows you to run and drive
around a stunningly realized city will
no longer be available to claim via the
digital storefronts after today friday
july 8th if you've already added the
demo to your library and are worried
about deleting it off of your hard drive
feel free to do so as users that have
redeemed it from digital storefronts can
re-download at their leisure and that is
it for today's gamespot news thank you
everyone so much for joining make sure
to go to gamespot.com to get more
details on all these stories plus a
bunch of other stories that we couldn't
include in today's episode and we'll see
you next week